monsieur Roger avait justement été
installé le premier WC encore extérieur
pour chien il esquare Rochechouart dans
le 18e arrondissement de Paris
[Musique]
à Paris le gay le beau Paris éternel
qu'on ne nous prendra pas mais c'est
déjà fait par les chiens vise les amis
des bêtes et c'est vrai on ne peut pas
l'oublier sinon on glisse sur ces pavés
séculaires
[Musique]
près d'un million de chiens et chats
sont parisiens aussi ils aient de tant
de personnes à vivre en comblant leur
creux affectif mais ils vont là où ils
ont le droit de s'oublier sur les
Champs-Élysées où ils font en passant un
petit cadeau touriste ou dans une très
obscure impasse pour malfaiteur
inexpérimenté
les Parisiens s'émeuvent et les pouvoirs
publics Paris sera-t-il enseveli sous la
tonne quotidienne de déchets de nos plus
fidèles compagnons sombreront nous c'est
en tout cas un vrai problème
[Musique]
c'est spécial la butte évidemment il y a
un trait à regarder on met les pieds
[Musique]
abandonnés tous les chiens qu'il y a
partout quand tu auras quand la rage
arrivera à Paris elle est pas tellement
loin
que ça se passe
vous pouvez éviter de montrer sur votre
toile tout ce qui se passe sur le
trottoir et ben écoutez ça dépend
heureusement
[Musique]
alors qu'est-ce que vous préconisez
faire une première oh là le pauvre il a
eu peur on y va
14 ans
dans la journée
trois fois par jour
[Musique]
mais pour faire son ah oui pour faire
ses besoins elle va toujours en train de
voiture entre les voitures oui les
teckel boxer dalmatiens et autres
griffons mais quand il le peuvent parce
que la réglementation n'est pas observée
qui oblige normalement le conducteur de
garer son véhicule à 30 cm du trottoir
[Musique]
les Parisiens disent beaucoup de plus en
plus parisiens disent que les chats les
chiens contribuent à polluer Paris et à
la salle de Paris qu'est-ce que vous
préconisez moi je préconise que les
chiens ils nous ont Kikine parce qu'ils
emboutiennent tout Paris et ici
particulièrement c'est un vrai trottoir
la ici dans le 17e tous les
matins je nettoie le
trottoir
il faut
même dans même dans les dans les
ruisseaux mais les gens qui traversent
des fois ils mettent des pieds dedans ça
n'aurait pas existé les chiens devraient
pas exister
mais les les
propriétaires de chiens devraient les
dresser
il va leur fixe
non ça dépend ça dépend de mes services
ça dépend comment que ma femme est là
contre les voitures alors il va quand on
les arbres contre les voitures aussi les
abîme c'est pas ça sur un déchet de
chien non j'ai marché dessus comme tout
le monde
on a qu'à faire des des petits des
petits endroits ou qui pourraient aller
non et puis imposé dans le temps on peut
y a des impôts sur le chien maintenant
on en paye plus et alors comme ça il
pourrait il pourrait faire des choses
alors vous seriez prêt à payer un petit
quelque chose pour que la Ville de Paris
mette des tas de sable
ça montrait une somme une somme terrible
depuis 1931 c'était propre et quand on
était propre et depuis un certain temps
de partout la grotte jamais toujours
dans la rue
[Musique]
c'est trop ça les dangereux on dit des
milliers de Parisiens par voie de
pétition au service d'hygiène de la
ville or dans ses services monsieur
Roger avait justement fait installer le
premier WC en extérieur pour chien il
esquare Rochechouart dans le 18e
arrondissement de Paris mais il en
faudrait 6000
[Musique]
cette dame va vous remettre une petite
médaille
parce que vous avez un chien qui montre
le bon exemple
[Musique]
voilà ça y est on va le faire là
ça c'est pas bien parce qu'il va pas au
WC
il n'est pas un petit peu trop baptisé
quand on l'oublie à aller à un endroit
fixe votre chien c'est difficile ils
sont pas habitués encore mais peut-être
que la nouvelle génération de chien sera
vite alors ça les jeunes pas de faire ça
ensemble non
quand il y en a un qui est là j'attends
qu'il ait fini pour
les 600 contre tous les matins tous ces
chiens lui il caniche et puis celui-là
il se connaissent non à la fin bon on se
rencontre pour beaucoup
n'a pas pu attendre là l'instant voyez
qu'il fait juste à côté alors là en
général les gens ne font pas l'effort de
conduire leur chien si loin il laisse
leur choix leur chien fonctionnait là
immédiatement où il se trouve
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]